[موسيقى]
هل حاول احد في هذا العالم ان يغير بصماته
نعم فعلها جوندلنج وهو احد اشهر لصوص
ثلاثينيات القرن الماضي في الولايات
المتحده
غمس جون اصابعه في الحمض الحارق للنجاه من
تحقيقات الشرطه في سوء افعاله ذاق امر
الوان العذاب بالحرق وخضع لعلاجات كثيره
حتى شفي من الالم والتشوه لكن المفاجاه
كانت حين اراد ان يجني ثمره الامه بعد
الشفاء غمس اصابعه في المحبره لياخذ
بصماته على ورقه بيضاء فكانت النتيجه ان
بصماته القديمه هي نفسها الجديده لم تتغير
والخلاصه هناك امور لا تستطيع ان تغيرها
فلا تكن عنيدا كي لا تحرق اصابعك الى
العناوين
بوتين يعزي عائله بريجوجين فهل سيمشي في
جنازته
جديد فرنسا حظر عباءه المسلمات في المدارس
والجامعات
وزير الداخليه التركيه يفتح ملف العرب
المرحلين الى سوريا
معلمه هندوسيه ترفض اكل لحوم البقر وتاكل
لحوم الاطفال
حميتي يطرح خارطه طريق لكن سفيرا سداديا
يعلن وفاته معلومات ما موجود بقول المرحوم
هل افسدت اسرائيل طبخه التطبيع الليبي ام
ان المنجوس تقدح من راسها
[موسيقى]
مرحبا لن يمشي الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين في جنازه قائد ميليشيات مرتزقه
فاجنر
على الارجح لكنه لم يفوته الواجب قدم
القيصر الروسي تعازيه الحاره الى عائله
الفقيد واكد لها ان تحقيقا في قمه النزاهه
سيقيم الحادثه التي ادت الى سقوط الطائره
وموت بريجوجين ومن معه موت لم يفاجئ احدا
بطبيعه الحال في العالم فان دعوه زعيم
المرتزقه الاشهر كتبت قبل حين دون تحديد
التاريخ لماذا صيبت عين فجرت الطائره يقول
بهيج فالرجل ملياردير والحساد كثر يوجه
الرئيس الروسي رساله مواساه لعائله قائد
مجموعه فاغنر في اول تاكيد رسمي لمقتله
جراء طائرته بمقاطعه شمال موسكو
ثروه بمليارات الدولارات لزوجته وابنائه
الثلاثه لكنه خلف وراءه في امكنه اخرى في
اوكرانيا وروسيا وليبيا والسودان وغيرها
خلف ايتاما من مختلف الرتب والجنسيه
لكنهم وجدوا كافلا جديدا لهم فالمسيره
ستستمر بمن حضر ومن دخل السوق قتل وقتل
سوريا لم تتاثر بموت بريكوجين فالقصف
استمر كالعاده وواصل اصطياد الاطفال الذين
لم يتغير عليهم شيء وقد حرص احد الفنانين
في ادلب على تخليد ذكرى بائع القبور
بجداريه رسمها على ما تبقى من جدار بيت
اسره سوريه دمره القصف الروسي نحن الان في
بلده كان صفراء في جبل الزاويه قبل قليل
استهدفوا البلده بعده قذائف وصواريخ
احداها كان في هذا المنزل والذي ادى الى
استشهاد طفلين واصابه اخرين بجروح تتصاعد
الاحتجاجات في درعا والسويداء وعموم
المناطق السوريه فترد قوات الاسد وروسيا
بقصف المدارس في ادلب من كان شؤما على
الاخر ريجوجين ام حفتر مع بريجوجين لم
يربح الجنرال الليبي خليفه حفتر اي معركه
لكن للامانه لم ينتصر حفتر قبله ايضا
المهم لا يجب على حفتر والنفط الليبي ان
يقلقان بالرحيل زعيم فجنر لان فاجنر باقيه
وتتمدد باداره جديده يطمل نائب وزير
الدفاع الروسي المشير حفتر قبل موت
بريجوجين بساعات قليله بحسب التقرير لن
تبقى وحيدا ليبلغ هذه الكلمات صعد نائب
وزير الدفاع الروسي يونس
طائرته وتوجه الى ليبيا وقبل موت قائد
مرتزقه فاجنر بالساعات كانت الزياره كما
تقول وكاله البريطانيه وتوضح ان المسؤول
العسكري الروسي ابلغ خليفه حفتر بان قوات
الفاغنر ستتبع من الان فصاعدا قائدا جديدا
وستبقى في ليبيا تحت سيطره روسيا في ايامه
الاخيره قدم بريجوجين الدعم السريع للدعم
السريع مقابل سبائك من ذهب السودان في
حقائب
الجنرال حميتي بحسب الصحافه الامريكيه قبل
اسبوع من مقتله كشفت صح
يفه حطت في عاصمه جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى
للاطمئنان على عناصره المنتشره في القاره
السمراء وعددهم حوالي خمسه الاف وبعد فتره
قصيره هبطت الطائره هليكوبتر تابعه لشركه
فاجنر في مكان قريب من قصر بانجي وعلمتنها
خمسه قاده من قوات الدعم السريع السودانيه
لشكر بريكوجين على تزويدهم بصواريخ ارض جو
وقدموا اليه سبائك من الذهب وفق الصحيفه
الامريكيه
اصبحت بريكس بلاس مع دعوه ست دول للانضمام
اليها بينها السعوديه ومصر والامارات ورغم
الوعود الصيديه والروسيه لها بالانضمام
الا ان الجزائر لم تحظى بمقعد في المنظمه
الاقتصاديه بسبب تحفظ البرازيل والهند بلا
زغله قررنا دعوه الارجنتين ومصر واثيوبيا
ايران والسعوديه والامارات العربيه لكي
يكونوا اعضاءا دائمين في بريكس خطوه شكلت
حدثا مفصليا وصفها الرئيس الصيني الذي
يعزز بقوه حضوره في افريقيا الخارجه من
ارث استعماري غربي طويل بالخطوه التاريخيه
بوتين غاب عن قمه بريكس بسبب مذكره
الاعتقال الدوليه بحقه وقد مثله فيها وزير
خارجيته
الذي كان مسرورا جدا لدرجه انه تعمد
اطلاقا نكته من خارج سياق شخصيته
الابوهوليه مثل ابو الهول حيث اكتشف ان
عدد اعضاء مجموعه البريكس اصبح معادلا
لفريق كره القدم 11 فضحك الكابتن رئيس
الصين وبقيه اللاعبين ودفعت بسورجي لافروف
وزير خارجيه روسيا الذي يم ثل رئيسه
المطلوبه بالمذكره توقيف دوليه بتهم جرائم
حرب دفعت بهذا الدبلوماسي العتيق والجاد
الى مزاح في دلالات بالقول ان مجموعه
بريكس اصبحت مثل فريق كره قدم
يعطي سياسيون فرنسيون انطباعا للعالم بان
الشعب الفرنسي متطرف وكاره للاسلام
والصحيح انه لا يمكن تعميم التوصيفات
السيئه او الحسنه على شعوب باكملها
وزير التربيه الفرنسيه جابرييل التال اعلن
انه سيحضر ارتداء عباءه الفتاه المسلمه في
المدارس والجامعات بفرنسا واضع عن الخطوه
في اطار قيم الجمهوريه العلمانيه التي
ترفض ابراز الرموز الدينيه خارج المعابد
علما ان ارفع وسام في جمهوريته اسمه وسام
الصليب الاعظم جرام كروان ويمنح لكبار
الزعماء والسياسيين والشخصيات البارزه من
مختلف الاديان وقد علق هذا الوسام على
صدور زعماء دول اسلاميه برحابه صدر ودون
التوقف عند دلالته الدينيه هذا فضلا عن
وسام صليب الحريه لك روادو
وغيره من الرموز المماثله
نطولوا بالكم شوي ربما يشجع
الفرنسيين اناثا وذكورا في الشتاء القادم
على ارتداء العباءه والنقاب ايضا تجنبا
للسقيع اذا اكتمل طرد القوات الفرنسيه من
افريقيا وفقدان باريس مصادر الطاقه والمال
لتدفئه شعبها واطعامه ينصح عربي
نفرانكفوني محب لفرنسا
فالنزال ليست الاولى ولا يبدو ان الجابون
ستكون الاخيره غداه امهال المجلس العسكري
في النيجر السفير الفرنسي مده 48 ساعه
لمغادره البلاد احتشد انصار الانقلابيين
في ملعب سيني كوتشي في نيامي دعما
للعسكريين المحتشدون رفعوا اعلام بلادهم
اضافه الى لافتات تدعو الجيش الفرنسي الى
مغادره البلاد يجب على النيجيريين
الاستفاده من الذهب واليورانيوم ولدينا
نفط ايضا مع ذلك
تعيش ازمه في كل مكان بالعالم وتبحث عن
اعاده الحضاره اليها بحسب الرئيس ايمانويل
ماكرون
متعدده المستويات التي تعيش فرنسا على وقع
تفاصيلها يبدو انها دفعت الرئيس الفرنسي
الى وضع ما يشبه خريطه طريق لمعالجتها
عنوان هذه الخريطه هو اعاده الحضاره الى
فرنسا فهي تربويه واعلاميه واجتماعيه
وعائليه معارضون فرنسيون يعتبرون ان
ماكرون يقود البلاد بعقليه رئيس مجلس
اداره شركه خاصه دوله الشركات والمصارف
ورجال الاعمال وهو ما اثر حفيظه قسم كبير
من الفرنسيين الذين يرون ان الرئيس
وحكومته يتجاهلان عمدا حقيقه ان فرنسا
مهزومه سياسيا واقتصاديا واجتماعيا بسبب
الرغبه في بناء دوله الشركات والقطاع
الخاص على حساب الانتاج الوطني والتعليم
الرسمي والطبابه العموميه والسياده على
مقدرات البلاد
[موسيقى]
رحلت السلطات التركيه مؤخرا شابين مغربيين
الى الشمال السوري وكانت فضيحه في وسائل
الاعلام لكن اعيداء الى الرباط بالتعاون
مع السفاره المغربيه يقول وزير الداخليه
التركيه للزميل عبد العظيم محمد ويضيف بان
المغربيين ادعيا انهما سوريان ولا يحملان
اي جواز سفر بعد ترحيلهما من حدود اوروبا
التي حاول اللجوء اليها بقصه الشابين
المغربيين قيل في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
انهم مغربيون اخذتهم الشرطه بدون ان تتحقق
منهم وارسلتهم الى شمال سوريا في بدايات
العام 2023 حاول شاب مغربي التسلل الى
اليونان كما حاول شاب مغربي اخر التسلل
عبر الحدود الى بلغاريا قوه امن البلدين
او الشابين وسلمتهما لقوات حفظ امن الحدود
التركيه لم يتم العثور على هويات وعند
سؤالهما عن جنسيتهما قال انهما سوريان
سمعت بالقصه عبر الاعلام تواصلنا مع
السفاره المغربيه لدى تركيا وجلبنا
اللاجئين من اعزاز وتم ترحيلهما بيسر
وسلاسه الى المغرب ما تزال شكاوى السياح
العرب تسجل وتصور بسبب المواقف العنصريه
التي يتعرضون لها اثناء تجوالهم في
اسطنبول تحديدا انتقاما من المهاجرين
العرب والمسلمين ونسي هؤلاء المتعصبون ان
مؤسس الجمهوريه التركيه كمال اتاتورك الذي
تنتمي المعارضه العلمانيه الاساسيه الى
ثقافته هو مهاجر من اليونان الى تركيا
[موسيقى]
صاروخ الطائفيه والعنصريه هذا الاسبوع
انفجر في الهند مع توحش معلمه لا تاكل
لحوم الابقار لكنها تاكل لحوم الاطفال
ارهابا وارعابا
استفردت بتلميذ طفل مسلم وجعلت زملائه
يضربونه امام الجميع
المعلمه الضبعه كما وصفت لم تعجبها قوه
الصفعات وطلبت من التلاميذ ان يجعلوها
اقوى على وجه الطفل المسلم وهو يبكي بينما
من يجب ان يبكي هو امه تطاول عليها الكبير
والصغير ولا ترد الا بتعليق اوسمه تلمع
على صدر نارين درامودي رئيس وزراء الهند
الذي تتخوف منظمات حقوقيه من تعرض مسلمي
الهند في عهده وعهدته الى حمله اباده
جماعيه
بعد الضجه الاعلاميه خرجت المعلمه
بتبريرات لا تقنع احدا وراحت تتغنى
بمستويات التسامح والمحبه العاليه التي
تحملها هي واداره مدرستها لجميع الطوائف
في الهند فاذا كانت هكذا المحبه كيف سيكون
الحقد والطائفيه بالله عليكم
السفير السوداني لدى ليبيا ابراهيم محمد
احمد يعلن للزميل احمد طه عن وفاه قائد
القوات الدعم السريع الجنرال حميتي
اذا ما عندك المعلومه دي اخدها مني يقينيه
ومسؤول من الكلام اللي انا بقوله ده من
معلومات الشخصيه متاكد انه هذا الرجل رحمه
الله عليه فهمت
بينما كان السفير ينعي حميتي كان حميتي
يقترح خارطه طريق من عشر نقاط لحل ازمه
السودان ابرز ما فيها الحكم الفيدرالي
وانشاء جيش جديد لا يتعاطى السياسه فهل
يعني هذا حصر السياسه بالميليشيات طالب
قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدانو
باعتماد الحكم الفيدرالي في السودان وقال
انه الانسب للبلاد وطرح هذا مبادره جديده
ضمنها 10 مقترحات لتجا الازمه الحاليه
وتضمن مقترح الدعوه الى تاسيس جيش جديد
قومي ومهني ينقى عن تجاذبات السياسه وفق
تعبيره مشيرا الى ضروره مشاركه ما يسميها
بحركات الكفاح المسلح في الحل سياسي رئيس
مجلس السياده السوداني الجنرال عبد الفتاح
البرهان رد سريعا على مقترح حميتي رافضا
التفاوض معه بغير البندقيه او الاستسلام
مجددا تخوينه ووصفه بقائد المرتزقه لكن
مبادره قائد قوات الدعم السريع اصطدمت
برفض قاطع لقائد الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان
مشيرا الى ان الجيش لن يعقد صفقه اماما
وصفهم بالخونه كل الشعب السوداني واقف مع
الجيش وكله وحداتنا في كل مكان واقفه وقفه
واحده عشان تهزم هذا التمرد عشان تهزم هذه
الخيانه عشان تهزم
هؤلاء المرتزقه
وعد رجل متزوج عشيقه له بالزواج وطلب منها
الا تفشي السر ريثما يتمكن من اقناع زوجته
واهلها لكن العتيقه العجوله نشرت على
حسابها في فيسبوك صوره لها مع زوج
المستقبل وكتبت ترقبوا زواجنا
فافسدت خطه الرجل الذي تبرا من كلامها
واعلن انه مخلص لام العيال ولن يعدد عليها
حكايه صالونات لكن هذا ما فعلته تماما
اسرائيل فكشفت عن لقاء جرى الاسبوع الماضي
في روما بين وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي
ايلي كوهين ونظيرته الليبيه نجلاء المنقوش
وبحسب ما اوضحت الوزاره فان الاجتماع الذي
تم خارجيه الايطاليه ناقش ثقه والعلاقات
بين البلدين وسبل الحفاظ على التراث
اليهوديه الليبي هذا وقال كوهن ان اللقاء
مع الوزير منقوش يشكل الخطوه الاولى
للعلاقات بين البلتين بعد اشتعال الشارع
الليبي رفضا للتطبيع سارع الرئيس حكومه
الوحده عبد الحميد دبيبه الى اتخاذ عده
خطوات اولها وقف وزيره الخارجيه عن العمل
واحالتها للتحقيق ومنعها من السفر بتهمه
مخالفه القانون الليبي الذي يجرم التطبيع
مع اسرائيل
الديب زار ايضا السفاره الفلسطينيه
متوشحا الكوفيه وكاد ان يعلن الزحف نحو
القدس لكن السوشيات نقلت عن مسؤولينا في
حكومه الوحده ان الدبابه هو من اعطى الضوء
الاخضر لوزيره خارجيته بلقاء نظيرها
الاسرائيلي خلال زيارتها ووزراء ليبيين
اخرين الى روما وقد عزز موقع والاسرائيلي
الفرضيه بكشفه عن توبيخ امريكي لاسرائيل
بسبب اساءتها لجهود واشنطن وبحسب ما نقل
موقع ولا الاسرائيلي عما وصفهم بالمسؤولين
الامريكيين والاسرائيليين فان اعلنكوهن
اضر بجهود واشنطن للتقريب بين اسرائيل
والدول العربيه وانه يشكل تهديدا امنيا
للمصالح الامريكيه في ليبيا مشيرا الى ان
مكتب رئيس الوزراء رتب اللقاء الذي استمر
نحو ساعتين بالتنسيق مع نجلاء المنقوش وفق
ما ذكرته وكاله
محتجون ليبيون يضربون النار امام مبنى
رئاسه مجلس وزراء حكومه الوحده الوطنيه في
العاصمه طرابلس الاجتماع تم الاتفاق عليه
مسبقا وعلى اعلى المستويات في ليبيا وقد
استمر لاكثر من ساعه وزيره الخارجيه
الليبيه نجلاء المنكوس هل تقدح من راسها
هل تتصرف من تلقاء نفسها في العمل
الدبلوماسي سئل رئيسها عبد الحميد دبيبه
قبل مده وهكذا اجاب هل انت متحكم في
تصريحات وزيره الخارجيه وقراراتها حقيقه
بالنسبه للسيده وزير الخارجيه تعمل وزيره
خارجيه في حكومه الوحده الوطنيه
ما تتكلم به هو ما يتكلم به عبد الحميد
الدبيب يا رئيس
السؤال الاخير في هذا الملف هل يتسابق
الطرفان الليبيان المتنازعان حكومه الوحده
وقوات الجنرال حفتر على اقامه العلاقات مع
اسرائيل خصوصا ان نجد حفتر صدام زارت
الابيب في نوفمبر 2021
بحسب تسريبات اسرائيليه ايضا
[موسيقى]
لا تصدق خبيره تغذيه يقول لكم ان الانسان
لا يستطيع ان يعيش بتناول وجبه طعام واحده
في اليوم
واستمعوا الى القيادي بحركه الشعب التونسي
هيكل المكي ماذا يقول ما تعرفوش ان الرئيس
ما هوشا يمكن يخدم 15 16 ساعه اليوم جميل
لكن والرئيس ياكل وجبه واحده في اليوم
المنظومه الاقتصاديه نحبسها سيدي الرئيس
عندك صلاحيات الانس والجن بمقتضاه دستور
25 جويليه اضرب كل الرخص هاي فرص تحكي على
الكارتيلات اول ما نحكي على الكارتيلات
حكينا عليها احنا بحركه الشعب وخاصه
كارتيل البنوك بورصه الترشيحات للانتخابات
الرئاسيه المصريه في العام القادم سجلت
اول ترشح رسمي وكان من جانب رئيس حزب
الوفد المصري المعروف بولائه للرئيس عبد
الفتاح السيسي من امام ضريح سعد زغلول
مؤسس حزب الوفد قبل اكثر من 100 عام يعلن
رسميا عن اول مرشح لانتخابات الرئاسه
المصريه المقبله
في الحزب بخوض الانتخابات رغم انه كان من
ابرز داعم الرئيس السيسي يعني مازلت بتؤيد
الرئيس السيسي لا فرق اؤيد الدور التاريخي
في 2012 لا انا لا اوافق على السياسه
السياسه الاقتصاديه سياسه التعليم وزير
مصري اسبق انتقد ما وصفها بعمليه البحث عن
كومبارس لمنافسه الرئيس السيسي في
الانتخابات عمليه البحث عن
منافسه السيد الرئيس مسرحيه ما بتقنعش حد
فما بتقنعش
عامل وناس خايفه وناس خايفه
في المقابل يؤكد النائب حسام الدين صالح
ان المصريين حريصون على التجديد للسيسي
ردا للجميع والاعلامي يوسف الحسيني يؤكد
ان الرئيس السيسي قدم لمصر ما لم يفعله
احد لها في التاريخ الحديث اقف امام اسم
الرئيس وانا من قلبي من جوايا
انظر اليه بمنتهى الاعجاب مش هقول لك
بالحب بمنتهى الاعجاب مش بس بالفخر بمنتهى
الاعجاب قال لي انت بتحبه واقول لك والله
العظيم قوي
وهتعدي السنين وهتلاقيني زي ما انا كده
قوي عمل اللي محدش عمله خالص في تاريخك
الحديث خالص
[موسيقى]
ختاما كان ملك اليونان الكسندر الاول
يتمسك كعادته رفقه كلبه المفضل داخل
حدائقه الملكيه فاقدم الكلب على مهاجمه
احد القرده احتدم العراق فتدخل الملك
محاورا سحب الكلب من المعركه لكن قرضا اخر
ظن انهما اصبح اثنين في مواجهه اخيه
فانقضى على الملك واشبعه عضا عميقا من
رقبته الى رجله ثم انقضت الجوله لكنها
ايام قليله وتسوء فيها صحه الكسندر الاول
حيث تعفنت جروح قدمه مما استوجب تدخلا
جراحيا لبتر ساقه لكن الاطباء رفضوا تحمل
مسؤوليه البتر خوفا من النتيجه
ففارق الملك الحياه وهو في ريعان سبابه
الخلاصه لا تستخف باحد فالقرد يتحول الى
اسد ان حاصرته والاسد يصبح اليفا ان
اكرمته الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]